hey this is cliff a rule and I'm here on  bleacher report playing start bench cut  oh all right we got to start the  moonwalk because that's the classic  everybody's still doing it you [ __ ] the  dougie although I got fresh prints on we  got it we got to cut the cars in there  that's hard  all right so it's arena with Tom Brady  and Tiger Woods yeah you know what you  start telling Brady you benched Sarina  sorry tiger sorry tiger yeah  [ __ ] you later all right you got to have  the wings so you start the wings  you [ __ ] the pizza and you cut the do  grants all day yeah oh that's easy  start Beyonce your bench Janet Jackson  and cut teddy bear oh you you start  super speed [ __ ] super strength and  celebrity is Patti oh no I don't want to  hear I don't want to know what people  are thinking yeah I can see that can  take you down a different path you might  hate people at your love now I'm good  hey this is cliff Avery and I just got  done playing start [ __ ] cut